- It's story telling,
It's creativity,
it's marketing dynamics.
It's re-selling,
it's collectability.
I mean, It's like creating my own Pokemon,
or Star Wars or Smurfs.
Are you kidding me?
- (music)
- [Narrator] You've got your perspective.
(car engine reeving)
(crowd cheering)
- [Narrator] I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
( upbeat music)
- Ladies and gentlemen, thank you so much
for tuning into what is,
it's a special episode of the scoop
because I'm kind of getting
a little bit outside
of my scope.
We've been getting tons of inbounds
from people who listen to the show.
And then of course some of my more,
annoying is a little mean,
but some of my persistent colleagues
who have been asking me
to get someone on the show
to talk about the momentum
maybe even the mania
we're seeing across the NFT market.
And we've got quite the guests
for you ladies and gentlemen.
We have Gary Vaynerchuck.
He is the CEO founder of VaynerMedia
early social media adopter and investor,
in the likes of Facebook,
Uber, founder of Rezi,
co-founder of Rezi.
And is a huge name in
collectible trading cards
and has really staked a flag
for himself in the NFT market.
So Gary, we were talking a little bit
before we turned on the mics.
People have an idea of your background,
but where exactly do
NFTs fit into your story?
And walk us through how
you kind of got introduced
to this burgeoning corner
of the crypto market.
- Man, thank you so much for
having me first and foremost.
It's really goddamn,
let me start with this.
I literally out loud said the following,
"dear God are you fucking kidding me?"
How did you possibly give me this gift
of taking every ingredient
of the last 40 fucken 5 years of my life?
I'm using all the curses
cause I want to be authentic
exactly what I said.
I cursed with God, which
is why I know it's okay
by the way,
and create this thing called NFTs,
that's literally everything
for me like supply and demand, creativity.
Like I've had people
from sixth grade reach
out to me and say,
"Gary, this is crazy, I used
to think like you move",
I moved in seventh grade.
They're like "you moved in seventh grade",
but when I would think
of you or when you popped
on the internet and I was like,
"wait a minute, I know that person".
I was like, Oh, a businessman.
I thought he was going to be an artist
because I doodled so much
in grammar school because
I was such a bad student.
So the whole time I would
just draw on my notebook
and like give out, like
draw on the chalkboard.
So not only is this IP.
I've always been obsessed
with WWF Disney "IP".
I would always...
Like, I loved star Wars.
I would always go to garage
sales and buy Happy Days,
and Alpha and RoboCop and
Get Along Gang and Sesame.
Like I've always had this infatuation
with pop culture art, right?
I've also, I'm very pro artist in general.
I've always been like, man
I don't understand the economic chain
of these secondary markets.
Like, look at these colors and
I'm a collector and a seller
but like, damn I feel like
the person that made it.
So like this whole royalties aspect of NFT
up building communities I was just,
I think the biggest thing
that people don't understand
about NFTs is the artists and projects
that are gonna win are not gonna be just
on the subjective nature of human's belief
that this is pretty cool, rad interesting.
I think it's going to be based
on who knows how to build community.
And these artists are
gonna to love the fact
that they get more of the royalties
but what they're not gonna
love, for some of them is
that galleries and other
people managers were
the ones that cultivated the
stories and the communities
not the artists themselves.
These artists that can do both
are gonna be incredibly fortunate.
I think the NFTs right
now are talking about art
and collectibles,
but I think the whole space for my startup
technology DNA speaks to me,
cause I think this is about transactions
on ledgers in a transparent,
decentralized way.
You're talking about selling homes,
mortgages, Insurance.
I think this is going to impact the music
and publishing industries in a way that I
don't think people understand.
This is a big, big deal.
And it's happening at a time of my career
where I have audience,
which will be helpful.
I'm also coming on the back
of a four year run in sports cards.
When I first started talking
about it in 2018, everybody laughed at me.
There wasn't a single smart
person on board with me.
That sports cards were going to happen.
None of them.
And I have a lot of them around me.
- [Frank] mmmh
- So now I have the affirmation
of calling something that a
lot of people in my circles,
who clearly did not see
alternative investing.
We have the momentum of the
Bitcoin and the ICO collapsed.
I'll get into that in a minute
behind us recently, not 2000
which is my comp for what I'm
about to say about NFTs.
It's storytelling,
it's creativity,
it's marketing,
marketing dynamics,
It's reselling,
it's collectability.
I mean, it's like creating my own Pokemon
or star Wars or Smurfs.
Are you kidding me?
All investing in those things.
It's personalities like Logan Paul,
and Charli D'Amelio and DaBaby and Gunna.
These are all humans that
I was on super early,
cause I understood what they were up to.
All those dynamics will play out.
So I was thanking God
for creating something that I will be
in the NFT space for the rest of my life.
- [Frank] mmmh.
And it's certainly
creating something that is
allowing when we think
about the value proposition
or at least how I've
come to understand it.
allowing artists musicians
to have more ownership
over the things they create.
And in terms of brands, if we think
about what it means for
brands we saw this morning,
Taco Bell went live with their
NFT, Taco art on referable.
Another way for brands to
engage with their users,
How do you see some of the
firms you're working with?
I think your clients includes
TikTok, Pepsi, some others.
How do you see big corporations,
maybe leveraging NFTs?
- My intuition is poorly.
That's my intuition.
And I'll tell you why?
- What do you think of
the Taco Bell thing is..
- I saw the head...
I need to see the metadata,
right?
So like these projects are gonna rely
on the metadata more than on
the front facing creative.
There's going to be too much supply
for NFP projects to be successful at scale
just on the merit of the creative.
I think what people don't
understand is the contracts
behind the art,
that enable a lot of things.
So what I don't know is,
is there a golden Taco?
that if you own it,
you have free Taco Bell
every time you go to one.
Like the metadata, is
what I think these things
are gonna really rely on.
So, my intuition with
just a headline reading,
and so I hate doing this.
My gut is that Taco Bell,
once again, cause it's been good at this
understands there's a trend
and got itself into the
new cycle of using it.
The merit of the program, my
concern is somebody is gonna
buy it for 20 bucks or 9 bucks or 4 bucks.
Somebody's gonna re-buy
it for a 100 bucks.
Somebody's gonna own it for $500.
And then it's gonna be
holding the bag when
it's not worth $500.
And I think that's going
to happen 97% of the time
over these next two years.
My prediction, whether right
or wrong is irrelevant,
But my intuition is you gonna see an ICO
and a internet 2,000 stocks dynamic here.
Which is the macro is right,
cryptocurrency is right.
Which is why there was
even that ICO movement.
NFPS are right.
The digitalization, the
provenance, the ecosystem
is gonna happen.
Right?
What happens in the early days where
there's no restriction to be in the game.
It is very easy for even a
person that knows nothing
about NFTs, right this
minute to Google and YouTube
for four hours and have
their first NFT on open seat
tonight.
- [Frank] mmmh
- That's a very...Please.
- No, I was going to say I'll take you up
on that and see if I can,
- Yeah. You should do that.
And I'll tell you why you should do that.
And everybody listening should do it.
The greatest way to learn, is doing it.
You can read about push-ups.
It's a lot better to do them.
And so, but what I think is gonna end
up happening is from
Taco Bell to McDonald's,
from Pokemon to Star Wars,
from every 16 year old
digital artist on earth,
to everybody like me, who's had
this hidden little art talent
that they've never shared.
Everybody is gonna be an artist.
Just like everybody became an influencer.
At some degree, everybody
became a personal brand.
Whether they like it or not.
Everybody has a social media footprint.
I wanna say everybody,
of course, not everybody,
but like a lot.
hundreds of millions of
people, billions of people.
I think you gonna see the same thing.
Now imagine what that means.
It means that the early stuff right now
on the hype are getting
a lot of the economics.
But there's gonna be too much supply,
and only the 1% are gonna be
these incredible economies.
And oh, by the way, no different
than when Star Trek came out,
just to remind all the nerds.
Cause I'm one.
There was a million space movies
in between Star Trek and Star Wars.
And you know, black hole is good IP
but it's not worth what
fucken Star Wars is worth.
Right?
- [Frank] mmmh
- You know, Planet of
the Apes is pretty cool,
but it's not worth what
star Wars is worth.
And I think that's what
you're going to see.
But I do think that
there's gonna be a collapse
on a lot of projects.
And I think people have
to be very thoughtful
about the macro up NFT and
separating that movement
from the NFT projects, no different
than separating the internet
from internet stock companies
and companies like pets.com
and eToys, they failed.
But to remind everybody, Amazon
was part of that group too.
And that was a very good investment
in the year 2000 when all the markets died
and that's how I plan on playing it.
- So we've kind of looked
at the macro backdrop of
what you see happening.
I wanna zoom in for folks
who are maybe listening
and still don't necessarily get the value.
Right? If we, we wind back the clock
to when we had the Cambrian
explosion of social media,
you can sort of look back and say
brought us closer together,
allowed us to communicate in ways
we've never been able
to communicate before.
On an individual level,
I can add my cousin that I
haven't seen in five years
and we can catch up about his
dogs or whatever have you.
What is the parallel for NFTs?
How do we communicate
that same type of value
that seems so easy to do in hindsight?
- if people collect anything,
seeing the ledger the
provenance of that matters.
So let's play it out.
Just, I'm gonna to ask both of you.
Just for fun.
- Yes. And Andreas is here as well.
- Yeah. Andreas is here for
everybody who's listening.
- (laughs) from the
underbelly of the scoop.
- Yeah, he's the man behind the curtain.
- Yeah. And I wanted to bring you both
in this cause it's a fun question.
What's your favorite movie of all time?
- I think I'm gonna have
to go with Godfather 1.
- Great. Is there any level
of curiosity for you to figure
out who the first person
to buy the first ticket
to the first showing of Godfather 1 was?
- Yah. That would be...
- That's all you need to know.
And it's very important
because I'm using a very
narrow example that
everybody can understand.
I believe that people do not realize
that we're social creatures.
For example, I think Frank that you have
a mustache right now,
because you want to
communicate to the world
something about yourself with it.
I'm being dead serious with you.
And I think Andreas has long hair,
and I think people wear Gucci belts
and buy Nike Air Force
1's and drive Mercedes
and care about having a blue checkmark
on Instagram and buy Fortnite
skins and Madden tokens.
And I can give you 47
other trillion examples
to why this is gonna work out,
which is the following,
humans want to communicate with humans.
So for example, everybody
listening right now
they meet someone new
whether they think they're
cute and they wanna date them
or they wanna do business with them,
and they thought it was
something important.
They will go to either commonly
in today's world, Google
to Google them or Instagram
to see what they're about.
Those are two things that
I think the three of us
or if I'm not supposed to
keep bringing Andreas in,
Frank you can agree with me.
That is what people do, right?
I think we can all agree.
I believe that when I meet you in 12 years
and I'm already enjoying this convo,
I'm gonna go to your public ledger
and I'm gonna search.
And I'm gonna see that you also,
are into Snarks,
the rare underwater Smurfs from the 80's
or you're into Bulltron or this and that,
because I'm gonna see it.
And I'm gonna...
I'll give you another example.
I'll be able to see that you
were one of the first 500 fans
of Nirvana,
because Nirvana in 2027,
put out their first demo
and sold NFTs against it.
And it will document who
knew who Nirvana was.
And that would have happened
in 1991 if NFT was around.
I can give you another point of view.
Nirvana may sell 10% of its first songs
master, it's demo tape master.
And you might be able
to get 1% commissions
because you bought it
like there's a lot here
and I'm going fast and
giving some random examples.
But social currency is the
word that people have to
wrap their head around with NFTs.
- [Frank] mmmh
- And I believe the
ledger, like I'll give you
another example.
If NFTs have been around
forever, I'd probably
be looking right now on the blockchain,
on the ledgers to find things that Randy
the Macho man Savage, once owned.
cause I wanna own them in my wallet,
because I care about Providence
and that's going to become
the biggest "Aha" to everybody.
When I said everybody
would online date in 1999,
my buddies made fun of me so heavy,
because in 2001 if you were online dating,
you were quote unquote,
a fat weird guy in your mom's basement.
- [Andreas] (Laughs)
Tinder in 2017.
- I think that might be the
prototype of NFT's today.
So we'll see if we
- And so, I think today when
people are like why do
I care about a JPEG?
I can just take a
screenshot, are going to be
the same people that are gonna
be in 21 years being like
"uh"
- It's interesting because
this is basically one
of the biggest arguments against the value
of NFTs is that the
ownership is really only
in the certificate of authenticity.
and because
- Because people,
Andreas I'm sorry to interrupt.
Cause I'm so excited.
It's because people haven't
taken the chess move
of everybody knowing and
seeing the certificate.
- So you're saying everyone's wrong.
This is a feature.
It's not a bug,
and that is the true value.
Who cares if it can be duplicated?
it's that you have that
certificate of authenticity
down the line and it might change hands
but everyone can see that
Gary was the first owner
of a particular top shop
moment or something.
- That's exactly what I'm saying.
And I would tweak it
in 89% of people are horribly
wrong about screenshot.
It doesn't mean anything
and 11% currently really,
really understand and will reap
the fruits of the benefit Comma.
I think top shots, one of
the most interesting projects
because it established Flow Rohams beast.
- Yeah.
- It's basketball.
It's made it pop culture.
On the flip side, I think the 98%
of the top shot values will collapse.
And I'll tell you why?
Not because Tom shot's bad or Roham's bad,
or Dapper's bad.
They're actually incredible.
It's because it's like sports cards.
There's too many different players.
Like nobody's gonna care in 21 years
about a Terry Rozier dunk,
even though he's a great player,
it's just not gonna happen.
Like, and I know that
because Kevin Garnett
rookie cards are too under priced
given his top 100 basketball
player of all time status.
It's not how collecting
those kinds of things works.
Not every Pokemon is worth a lot.
Charles Ard is worth a lot.
And so where people getting caught,
is they're looking at the whole project.
And I think they're gonna get caught
because there's no
demand issues right now.
Excuse me, no supply issues.
We don't have the NFL NFT.
We don't have MOB NFT.
We don't have UFC NFT.
We don't have Pokemon, star Wars, WWF,
but we're going to Muhammad Ali, Pele,
like Harry Potter, like it's all coming...
- And that's a point,
it's gonna have an impact.
- A huge impact.
So I think, LeBron's NFT on
top shot as a first project,
and LeBron is really
potentially quote unquote
under priced long-term.
But I think you're gonna
see the floor collapsed
out of it on the individual stuff.
Cause I don't think the demand
will be able to sustain it,
cause that demand for that guy
and that girl is about to amortize
out to 45 other IPS that
haven't hit the market.
- Yeah. And across an array
of different categories and...
- And there is a lot of supply
of those things like that.
Top Shot's doing a great
business model for themselves.
I think kudo, like I
love what they're doing.
I do think though that Top Shot is gonna
have a beanie babies-like moment.
I really do.
And I don't say that happily.
I actually think overall
that company is a monster.
And even the MBA Top Shop
program, I think is a monster.
- Yeah
- I'm talking about the
individuality in it.
That's like saying like, in
sports cards I've been saying,
I don't like these young rookies,
I think they're overpriced.
But I love sports cards.
I love Top Shot.
I don't like 90% of the inventory
and they're very expensive right now.
Karma at the Macro.
I'm obsessed with NFTs, but I
think there's all the dynamics
in place for a lot of the NFT projects
of today to be worth a lot less money
in 24 months because there's
an inevitable correction
and then there'll be the birth.
And I keep using Amazon and eBay,
as two stocks that
everybody should have bought
in you know, May of
2020. Excuse me, 22,000.
Even though the internet
bubble was a monstrous one
and everybody started writing articles.
The Internet's a fad.
That's what's going to
happen with NFTs in two years
everyone's gonna be like,
see NFTs were bullshit.
That's not true.
what's gonna happen is a lot
of those projects were mispriced.
But the overall macro
thesis of NFTs is similar
to the overall thesis
of the internet in 2000.
- And there's definitely a
number of investors who are
of that same opinion as we reported
back in mid-February, Dapper labs is
in the process of wrapping
up a $250 million round
at a valuation of somewhere
around $2 billion.
So there's definitely
people who see value in this
- That's a monster, but guess what?
I don't know the details,
but the economics
around their Top Shot
deal has to be enormous.
And, and the other thing is
let's not forget who Roham
and the team are.
They did CryptoKitties in
2017, I think is the year.
This is a team that really fucken
understands this space,
and a $2 billion company
as a winning company
in 2031 is gonna seem like peanuts.
So, it's as crazy as it sounds.
It's not farfetched.
Now that team flow is a public,
all of that has to work out,
but yeah, no, I get it.
- I wanna double click really quickly
on maybe some of the
impediments they might face.
Something that I've thought about,
the team has thought about
is whether or not certain
licensing agreements
might make things difficult?
Like there obviously have had
made arrangement with the NBA,
but if they were to
move on to other leagues
if they can't secure the
proper type of licensing
or their current licensing
arrangements fall through,
then what?
- My point to that is,
that's exactly right.
Brilliant. I agree.
Comma. They created CryptoKitties,
and so like to me, if
I would bet on a crew.
There're one of the crews I would bet on
cause they've shown the
ability to create IP,
not just license it.
ESPN scares me, because they
haven't started another sport.
They just rent it, and to your point,
when you lose the rights,
what happens?
and the NBA's not giving them
the rights and perpetuity
I don't know the details.
And to your point, all the
other ones are in play, right?
So I would say the following:
That's right.
Comma, their ability to create
IP is something that needs to
be thought through.
And I don't know who on
that team did that or what.
That would be what I would
have looked under the hood on
if I was investing.
To see if I felt that they
could stand up new things.
And I believe it is the IP creators
over the next decade,
that win the biggest.
- Andreas you wanna step
in here for a second?.
- Yeah, absolutely.
Gary, you've been kind of alluding
to this throughout this recording.
You basically have the clients,
you have the distribution
and you have the resources.
So what are you planning
for in this space?
Is there a banner NFT platform on the way?
and what kind of other
opportunities are you exploring
with your clients as well?
- On the client side
I'm definitely building
out internal expertise
of Vayner media, Vayner
X, my services business
to be able to help with, you
know, lightweight projects,
not fully launching NFTs
and things of that nature.
I am currently in the process
of really gathering my
thoughts on how big I...
To be frank Andreas, I'm a little bit...
and I'm not like this normally,
which is why I know this is a big one.
I'm a little...
I don't wanna use the word overwhelmed.
I can feel like the energy in my soul.
Like this is big for me,
and so I wanna be very
thoughtful on like how
I capture this energy,
but I can tell you the following.
These are facts.
Cause I want to give you some scoops
because I like you guys.
It's impossible that I go to the grave
unless I die very quickly
here, which would be very sad
without launching my own NFT product,
but it's not going to be Gary V photos.
Like I'm not doing the influencer thing.
There is no chance that I'm not investing
in the shovels and the
picks, the platforms.
I've already personally and more
institutionally feel that
I will invest in projects.
Meaning I bought some hatchbacks
and crisp crypto punks as Gary the human.
I plan on doing that more institutionally,
raising capital and doing that.
Raising capital and doing
it against companies,
which is very different than what I did
in Oh five, right.
In 95, I built on top of it.
While your library.com., I
believed in the internet.
In Oh five I was like, Oh, I've learned,
I'm not gonna just do that.
I'm gonna invest in the companies
and build up the Gary V
brand and that worked.
In 2021 with NFTs, I'm gonna
invest in the platforms.
I'm gonna invest in projects,
Cause I'm good at it.
It's like sports cards, and I
think I have the creativity.
What I did forget.
I'm the brains behind Gary V.
And I think I can do that
to something more scalable,
all three are in the cards for me, sir.
- So you're gonna be busy.
So we appreciate you making the time here,
to unpack this for us
and to kind of, I guess
pop the scoops, NFT cherry.
So we appreciate that.
Gary V. Thanks for coming on.
- Thanks for having me.
Final part, I pay attention
to a lot of things.
You're doing really good work.
Keep it up.
- YouTube, What's up?
It's Gary V.
First of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you,
please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration
of YouTube is about to
explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise, and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.